[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du sud culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi à 10
janvier une deuxième édition axée sur la
fine fleur de la musique house et techno
le festival électro chic revient à
versailles grand parc au mois de mars
une nouveauté cette année un tremplin
pour trouver la nouvelle star électro
auto est un vieil ours en peluche offert
avant la guerre un jeune allemand de
confession juive
il va tout connaître de la seconde
guerre mondiale la compagnie o'navio aux
traces son histoire mouvementée et une
passion amoureuse dévorante destructrice
avec un mois à la campagne
ivan tourguéniev nous transporte dans
l'art au 6/9 siècle alain françon la met
en scène dans sa nouvelle création
trois jours de musique house et techno
du 15 au 17 mars au festival électro
chic cet adversaire remparts qui ont
fait le point avec le de rigoureux aux
beaux jours
alors vous êtes le secrétaire général de
l'onda vélizy-villacoublay qui est l'une
des salles qui participe une grosse
programmation faite de concert de mix de
conférences et d'ateliers tout à fait
donc la deuxième édition du festival à
nerfs qui était vraiment autour de la
french touch puisqu'on parle de cette
idée que on est dans le berceau de
secours en cas vraiment révolutionné la
musique électro dans les années 90 et
donc comme on n'a pas envie de faire la
même chose cette année
il ya toujours cet esprit électro pop
mais on ouvre aussi à des taxes en plus
plus house et plus techno et cette année
la dixième édition est une nouveauté
puisque vous proposer un tremplin où
vous souhaitez découvrir les nouvelles
pépites
c'est ça donc on veut donner leur chance
à des nouveaux artistes être un peu les
révélateurs
sachant qu'il ya plein d'artistes voilà
qu'on était quand qui sont versaillais
qui ont ensuite deux ont eu des
carrières internationales on conçoit dit
que peut-être que nous aussi on peut
apporter notre petite pierre à l'affût
tu le futur édifice de l'électro
mondiale alors on peut encore s'inscrire
et reste
moins d'un mois c'est jusqu'au 31
janvier faut être versailles et faut
être où on peut venir de partout
c'est ouvert à tous c'est jusqu'au donc
au 31 janvier
c'est plutôt des artistes voilà qui sont
pas professionnels qui veulent se lancer
justement qui cherchent une oreille un
public donc qu'ils nous envoient chacun
deux morceaux et une reprise et donc il
y aura un comité qui se réunira en haut
lieu pour décider après ce la date du 31
janvier des cinq finalistes qui
présenteront en fait le remix devant le
public de l'undd une place de choix pour
commencer ce qu'ils ouvrent le festival
chez vous le 15 mars c'est ça il ouvre
et leurs finalistes parce que le public
va voter aussi à partir de ses cinq
concours en leurs finalistes donc fera
partie de la programmation au même titre
que les autres artistes invités sera
vraiment un voilà un des
des artistes fort de la prochaine
édition 2010 9 alors comme il y a
plusieurs en fils c'est versailles grand
parc l'agglomération cette année ya
notamment à chasser électro et saône
motion là c'est à jouy en josas le 15
mars mais les a pas que ça non il ya
aussi donc le théâtre montansier la
ville de versailles qui accueille les
livres est étonnant c'est ça écran mais
très french touch dans l'esprit donc de
l'impératrice dans un groupe très
intéressant qui fait plutôt l'électro
pop y lire une soirée aussi à
saint-cyr-l'ecole une soirée ciné
concert avec basile d'immenses qui est
de la romance et puis les trois autres
soirs donc cela avait dit six et
notamment le 16 mars quatre groupes ou
artistes chapelier fou romont poncet
pandorum et dance dance dance tout à
fait sachant particulier cvc ouais c'est
une soirée on voyagera avec des
sonorités plus techno et puis un after
de saône motion ci contre on regarde un
extrait de thé
[Musique]
alors c'est un choix un peu particulier
on l'a vu ça mais aussi du cinéma
oui tout à fait donc ses c'est arsenal
c'est un groupe belge qui inaugurera en
fait la soirée du 16 donc c'est une
proposition entre cinéma et musique
électronique et le l'histoire c'est la
rencontre entre la ruralité japonaise et
les grandes villes comme tokyo
donc c'est un peu ce combat entre entre
les deux et une certaine angoisse qu'on
peut ressentir aussi dans ces grandes
villes un peu vertigineuse et ça donne
vraiment lieu voilà une orchestration et
un concert autant regarder cadence de
ses formats l'a complètement différente
c'est ça c'est à dire qu'il ya une
partie aussi du public des théâtres qui
peut rentrer aussi par l'électro par ce
biais là et donc avec un début de soirée
un peu plus à écouter à regarder avant
d'aller progressivement avec les autres
groupes vers la danse à l'an dernier
c'était surtout la french touch cette
année c'est internationale aussi ça
vient de partout les français chapelier
fou romane possémé aussi pandorum c'est
le serbe
ces desserts voilà donc on a envie
valade ouvrir aussi et il y avait quand
même une création électro qui est
international européenne ait eu avant
l'after de sa motion jeudi soir ils sont
la dernière partie est là on est dans
une techno voilà qui limite hardcore et
donc israël on se rapporte de la
transporte alors le 17 mars la laisser
le samedi la soirée notamment un groupe
hollandais s'est encore en train de se
finaliser
le groupe hollandais c'est d'être hot
swing donne avant d'en parler je propose
qu'on regarde un extrait
leur place sur la scène internationale
incontournable
oui parce que c'est un peu la nouvelle
génération de la hausse musique qui est
apparu dans les années 90 aux états unis
autour de chicago qui est ensuite allé à
new york
donc c'est un peu le renouveau de cette
forme dont qui mixe des des sonorités
qui vende de la salle de la funk
la hausse est aussi c'est aussi ce à
quoi avec des samples plus électro tout
un état d'esprit des années 90 qui le
font vivre dans ces vallées aussi aof
un petit à côté notamment pour les plus
jeunes parce que les dates sont pas sans
nécessairement sur tous les arts sont
pas nécessairement accessible a eu 11 17
ans a commencé une électro c'est ça donc
c'est l'après midi du 17 mars à londres
donc c'est pas en famille parce que
c'est vraiment pour pour les ados au son
de l'électro
donc c'est l'espace jeunesse de
vélizy-villacoublay la médiathèque de
viviez villacoublay et puis le l'école
de musique de vie des civils voulais
qu'ils se réunissent qui participent à
ce off et qui assure voilà ce cette boum
électro et puis ensuite il y aura un
atelier bidouille aussi un bidouiller
réparation c'est ça ben ça fait partie
aussi du monde électro c'est à dire que
dans électro il ya électronique donc il
ya tout un travail ou toute une
réflexion sur sur l'accessoire sur le
doubs vienne le sont parce que c'est des
sondes qui était à la base voilà qui est
qui qui qui sont pas des sons
d'instruments de musique au sens
classique mais faire de la musique avec
des accessoires industriel revisiter des
tournées merci avec moreau alors le
festival électro chic c'est du 15 au 17
mars et les places sont déjà en vente
on change de sujet on part au théâtre
avec du grand théâtre au russo
montansier à versailles alain françon
met en scène un mois à la campagne
vivante orgue et nief écrite en 1850 et
immédiatement censuré la pièce reçoit un
succès triomphal en 1909 une pièce au
coeur des tourments amoureux
une impression qui va devenir dévorante
un tourments amoureux
natalia petrovna is life la maîtresse de
maison s'éprend d'un jeune étudiant un
mois la campagne est l'oeuvre la plus
célèbre divan tourguéniev une création
censuré en 1850
c'est quand même très descriptif d'un
état la société russe dans les années
1850 tout gagner à d'ailleurs écrit un
essai qui s'appelle un homme de trop le
journal d'un homme ne trouve et c'est la
génération des jeunes gens quand ils
reviennent après avoir fait leurs études
à berlin
ils comprennent plus rien la sauce est
tous très traditionaliste alain françon
signe une mise en scène subtile et
délicate où l'interprétation retenu des
personnages masculins contraste avec les
mois féminin c'est aussi une pièce qui
fonctionne beaucoup sur sur les émotions
mais qui effectivement jusqu'à jusqu'à
flaubert et tourgueniev je veux dire
c'est seulement l'élite qui pourraient
avoir des émotions légende du pop était
jamais concerné par sa part les états
d'âme
et justement dans cette pièce comme dans
les romans tourgueniev vous comme chez
flaubert ou comme stendhal
tout à coup je vais dire tout le monde a
le droit une création au casting
d'exception menée par anouk grinberg les
is life vous invite à passer quelques
jours en leur compagnie
déjà 200 sont des citations grâce à
marvel ou dc comics et ils ont sans
doute bercé l'enfance de certains
d'entre vous et accompagne encore des
générations des super héros ou en fait
aussi établi leurs quartiers à
versailles puisqu'une association a été
créée et a créé ses propres personnages
le soir mélanie donc il ya barney et le
trasher gorgue des super-héros yvelinois
qui prennent vie grâce à la pluie et au
crayon des artistes de l'association et
lausanne comics leurs aventures sont
réunis dans un cinquième tome qui
sortira le 13 janvier alors on retrouve
tous les codes de ce genre de bande
dessinée des bagarres de l'humour et des
personnages plus ou moins héroïques et
décalé le président de l'association
nous en a présenté quelques-uns des
histoires que je scénarise entièrement
et puis à tour de rôle on se passe les
criantes mettre en images un univers
cohérent de super héros qui ont la
propre style indépendante mais qui sont
amenés à se croiser au fil des épisodes
la bestiole qui est une sorte de dôme
insectes la frappant c'est un petit pas
spiderman ci n'était pas alcoolique et
qui ne fait pas comme un pompier c'est
un parent tirs ont cessé complètement le
ultra chaud lui c'est une femme anti
héros c'est un vampire chasseur de
vampires donc là on arrivera dans la
gamme des personnages un peu plus
dérangeant va dire alors on pas tous les
citer mais il ya aussi barney qui est un
chasseur de monstres et borg est un
cyborg amnésique qui tue les criminels
et qui cherche son passé au fil des
épisodes
ils sont cinq et auteur et 15
dessinateur de toute la france à
travailler sur ces héros et
l'association elle même compte des
membres un peu particulier et oui aucune
obligation d'être un artiste pour y
adhérer on peut aussi être simple
lecteur un tout simplement
nicolas hamonou a créé le nan comics en
2011 et l'idée c'est vraiment de
regrouper les talents et les soutient
d'une certaine manière on anticipe
également un des festivals en fait
j'avais sorti voir j'avais sorti un
album à compte d'auteur en 2010 donc
album de bande dessinée qui manie de
faire la tournée un petit peu des
festivals pour dédicacer le louage est
sûre pas j'ai fait j'ai fait des
rencontres
qui ont permis en fait de voir que je
n'étais pas le seul en fait à essayer de
faire connaître comme ça et puis comme
on dit l'union fait la force et j'ai
proposé à ses auteurs de se joindre à
moi l'association à grenade pour essayer
de développer en commun et pour les
adhérents justement une publication leur
est réservé ces lots nan pocket
elle est déjà disponible là dès
l'adhésion valable pour un an et à 10
euros pour se procurer le cinquième tome
des lots nan heroes il faut donc
attendre le 13 janvier il est à 10 euros
également et peut-être que parmi eux il
ya le prochain stagner ou à bob kane
bon on espère on espère en tout cas voir
sa santé cro jeu non merci alors on
parle maintenant de poésie c'est le
grand écart dans les sujets depuis le
mois de décembre des poètes
contemporains détail leurs oeuvres avec
poésie ouverte une soirée mensuelle de
lecture et des shows avec le public
la première s'est tenue avec le pour
étendre les soeurs michael edwards qui
est aussi le directeur de l'académie
française c'était au tour de baudelaire
regardez ils sont vraiment les aveugles
de baudelaire le temps d'une soirée dans
l'écrin de la bibliothèque centrale de
versailles à la lecture sur michael
edwards directeur de l'académie
française et baudelaire quand j'écris en
français
simplement parce que il y as seul c'est
enchantement continue dans un poème de
baudelaire et je me dis que ce n'est pas
simplement parce que c'était un génie de
la pensée de la sensibilité de la
sensation c'est aussi parce que c'est
vraiment un génie de la forme un temps
de lecture suivie dans l'échangé avec le
public dans le cadre de poésie ouverte
un projet porté par dickens l'écrivain
et poète est actuellement en résidence
avec la ville de versailles en 2017 la
poésie c'est aussi autre chose sont des
façons de parler la langue d'enrichir la
langue dans rivière le sens une grande
diversité je pense que si on arrive à
aller vers le public et à
de cils et les poètes reviennent eux
même parler au public lire leur poésie
le contact permettra de mieux faire
comprendre ce que c'est que la poésie en
prochain rendez vous le 17 janvier avec
le dramaturge olivier cadiot
il parlera du pour être français
emmanuel hocquard et on poursuit sa 7 8
aux cultures avec notre notre nouvel
invité alban coulaud bonsoir vous êtes
le metteur en scène de la compagnie
o'navio et le 13 janvier
cette compagnie propose au total
l'autobiographie d'un ours en peluche on
y découvre donc le destin d'auto un
vieil or sont plus exactement et c'est
d'après un spectacle qu'on a créé
d'après d'après l'oeuvre de tomi ungerer
comme sont comme son nom l'indiqué est
l'autobiographie d'un ours en peluche
qui qui va qui va traverser qui veut
traverser le siècle le 20e
on commence juste avant la guerre de
39-45 pour finir dans les années 2000 on
commence en allemagne on termine à new
york
ouais c'est une espèce d'épopée c'est
celle à l'histoire la grande histoire
vue à travers le regard de cet ours en
peluche justement juste avant la guerre
nous qui va connaître 39-45 de
l'intérieur dont il connaît très
difficile la gestapo les bombardements
exactement oui en fait pour résumer un
petit peu l'histoire auto est offert
jeune enfant qui s'appelle david voilà
juste avant juste avant la montée de ce
qu'on peut imaginer juste avant la
montée du nazisme au pouvoir allemand et
david va être raflés son lourd sans plus
je vais être transmis à son meilleur ami
qui lui-même va le perdre dans les
ruines d'un bombardement qui va être
récupérée par par un soldat américain
qui vient voilà qu'il vient libérer
libérer l'allemagne voilà c'est une très
belle histoire
moi ce que j'ai aimé dans cette histoire
est généralement ce que j'aime aussi
dans ces épopées historiques c'est qu'on
raconte l'histoire mais à travers des
situations intimes à travers vraiment
des regards d'enfants
voilà et ça c'est une autre façon
d'aborder l'histoire pour moi qui est de
l'ordre de l'intimé du poétique
regardant ce que justement c'est resté
aux enfants parce que voir des huit ans
emportant des sujets difficiles comme ça
comment est ce qu'on les met en scène
comment est ce qu'on les présente
alors moi je fais partie des gens qui
pensent qu'on peut qu'on peut tout vous
raconter aux enfants
évidemment et évidemment il ya un âge
pour tout mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui
pour moi c'est plus intéressant de de
leur parler de ces choses-là
en tout cas de la guerre c'est pas le
seul sujet d'auto ou un finalement c'est
vrai qu'on parle beaucoup de ça mais
c'est pas le seul sujet j'ai
l'impression que c'est plus intéressant
d'aborder ces choses là de façon
poétique et distanciée plutôt que des
images qu'on peut prendre en pleine face
à la télé voilà quand on dit c'est un
peu trop dur pour des enfants de 8 ans
je dis regardez un petit peu ce à quoi
ils sont confrontés tous les jours c'est
bien plus violent que ça je crois
et puis vous vous inspirer de comme un
grand voile et c'est l'un des plus
grands auteurs pour enfants c'est oui
c'est presque le plus grand
auteur pour enfants entre autres parce
qu'il fait plein de choses pour moi pour
la petite histoire et vient juste d'être
d'être nommé chevalier de l'ordre du
mérite je crois
voilà c'est un vieux monsieur
aujourd'hui kaka 82e 3 ans vit entre
entre entre l'alsace puis saisit le
shetland qu'on n'a jamais pu rencontrer
malheureusement c'est raté à peu de
choses près on a joué en alsace il était
là mais il était malade il n'a jamais pu
voir le spectacle mais voilà c'est un
monsieur qui est vrai qu'on respecte
pour pour tout ce qu'il a écrit en
termes de littérature jeunesse mais
aussi comme engagement politique c'était
un très grand affichiste voilà dans les
années 60-70 quelqu'un qui a vraiment
lutter par ses dessins contre
l'apartheid contre le racisme contre
voilà contre toutes les injustices et
tout ça se retrouve évidemment dans
l'ensemble de son oeuvre pour enfants
mais en ce sens qu'il a une oeuvre qui
est aussi extrêmement d'euros les trois
brigands c'est lui par exemple pas pour
le situer les trois brigands sont
peut-être un peu plus connus parce que
porter à l'écran
voilà mais ces voix là c'est un grand
grand monsieur la littérature jeunesse
c'est évident et pour en revenir à votre
pièce la vôtre plus précisément vous
fait jouer des marionnettes c'est
peut-être ça aussi qui permet de faire
un décalage exact soit exactement alors
on fait jouer des comédiens qui
manipulent les marionnettes les
marionnettes ne joue pas tout seul sans
comédiens sans dernier 10e derrière
elles ne sont rien oui effectivement la
marionnette permet évidemment de créer
aussi une distance on est effectivement
à quelques moments du spectacle dans des
situations difficiles délicate et le
fait que ce soit de la marionnette
je dirais à créer créer une distance qui
permet de ne pas recevoir l'information
de manière extrêmement brutal voilà on
n'est pas face à un enfant qui subissent
des violences en face à une marionnette
qui représente un enfant qui suit les
violences quand même très très
différents aussi qui est aussi un jeu on
vous avez rencontré nos téléspectateurs
avaient pu voir flonflons et musette sur
notre antenne là aussi vous utilisez des
doudous là vous utilisez des
marionnettes ce sont des jouets
d'enfants aussi alors on a
sont pas vraiment des jouets d'enfants
mais en fait on est parti en gros en
personnages ilya auto et autour il ya on
va croiser à peu près 27 personnage est
en fait le travail qu'on a fait avec
avec la plasticienne qui a créé les
marionnettes on a travaillé uniquement
avec les matières qu'on pouvait trouver
dans un ours en peluche en fait dans un
vieil ours en peluche à savoir du coton
de la toile de jute et du fil c'est à
dire que les personnages sont
entièrement sculptée avec du coton et du
fil à coudre
donc on s'attache encore plus oui
j'avais déjà goûté les deux éléments
notre enfant les marionnettes sont
extrêmement attachante les personnages
sont extrêmement attachés et pour
renforcer encore tout ça on peut la
vivre à hauteur d'un ours
effectivement alors nous enlève on en
avait un double défi dire que moi j'ai
complètement supprimé le texte de tommy
longueur je n'ai gardé vraiment que la
trame
sauf que on est dans le cas d'une
autobiographie donc été la question
était comment revenir au regard de
l'ours a tout simplement on a créé une
espèce de vision subjective de l'ours
grâce à la magie entre guillemets de la
vidéo
voilà on a fait un travail vidéo un peu
particulier avec ce qu'on appelle du
mapping dire de dépôt des projections
qui sont qui sont extrêmement
précisément cadrés sur un décor qui est
mouvant quoi exactement
et du coup voilà du coup on est de temps
en temps on a notre point de vue de
spectateurs et en même temps qu'on a
notre point de vue en vidéo on a le
point de vue d'auto merci alban coulaud
cieux alors auto vous fait donc
découvrir son histoire et l'histoire le
samedi 13 janvier à la ferme de bel ébat
à guyancourt
un autre rendez-vous à guyancourt c'est
un hors les murs c'est aussi la ferme de
bel ébat ça se passe à la batterie avec
un récital de franz liszt qui est
proposée au piano où wilfrid imbert
lauréat notamment du conservatoire
national supérieur de musique de paris
il proposera un florilège des plus
belles pages du répertoire pour piano de
la musique classique aussi mais c'est à
coignières le théâtre alphonse daudet
accueille cinq musiciens autour de
robert schumann et gabriel fauré la
musique de chambre et écouter le lundi
16 janvier
on passe maintenant à notre page cinéma
le rendez vous cinéma de la semaine
c'est au grenier à sel à celle de
trappes del pino vous donne de quoi
remplir vos agendas pour commencer
l'année sinequa un mais deux coups de
coeur que je vous propose pour les
prochains jours nous avons tout d'abord
le vendredi 19 janvier à 20h45 le
dictateur de charlie chaplin qui a été
tourné en 1945 local des lumières du
grenier nous avons ensuite le mardi 23
janvier dans le cadre de la semaine du
son label et la meute
c'est le 7 un film qui a eu le tout
premier prix de la meilleure création
sonore à cannes en 2017 c'est une classe
d'un prix qui a été créée cette année
uniquement et il sera présenté par
pierre bateliers qui est ingénieur du
son il viendra nous parler de l'intérêt
et de l'importance du son avec les
images dans le cinéma et tout après nous
enchaînerons du 24 au 30 janvier par le
festival télérama le festival télérama
vous le savez c'est une sélection des
meilleurs films 2017 est une sélection
faite par le festival télérama et la
sélection sera réparti entre le signer
cet appel en cours et le grenier à sel à
trappes
il y aura en plus cette année d avant
première dans nos cinémas vous retrouver
tout ça en images sur notre site
internet cinéma grenier à sel point com
une famille qui se craquèle où les
non-dits se dévoile où les rancoeurs
s'avoue 27 fragments d'un désir est
jouée ce vendredi 12 janvier au théâtre
de chaire d'elancourt début de la
représentation
à 20h30 du 10 au 25 mars voisins le
bretonneux propose sa biennale de la
sculpture elle est ouverte à tous les
sculpteurs ville si loin extérieur et si
vous êtes intéressés
clôture des inscriptions le 6 février
prochain maguy marin vous invite à une
farandole macabre dans un rythme
obsédant
la chorégraphe française continuent à
questionner la place de l'homme dans le
monde
les violences du temps la compagnie
danse au théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le 13 janvier
extraits
[Musique]
les personnages et les chansons de
renaud prennent vie dans une aventure
musicale sur scène la doudou lucien manu
la teigne avril en septembre joue le
petit monde de renault au théâtre espace
coluche de plaisir ce samedi 13 janvier
regarde dans la boue blouson un beau
jeans et puis des data vient faire un
tour dans l'ariège
ce soir ton cousin walchi
[Musique]
et de l'humour pour terminer avec
françois xavier demaison dans son
spectacle il raconte ses dix ans de
scène une galerie de personnages drôles
et étonnants il est à voir sur la scène
de la ferme du mas des sceaux dimanche
regard du jem présente docteur lê biyani
je suis dans cette fratrie je suis aussi
je suis gynécologue
je suis une écolo parce que j'aime les
femmes
j'aime énormément
la normale hier série sévit les dossiers
des patients pour la visite
elle n'était pas très sage pour une
sage-femme trois soirs c'est la fin de
ce set 8 culture je vous remercie de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
manquerait du prochain pour un nouveau
numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]